THINK ABOUT THAT JOE MANCHIN,
KYRSTEN SINEMA!
JOSH HAWLEY IS THE SENATOR FROM
MISSOURI.
HE JOINS US NOW.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
JUST CAME OUT OF THE SENATE
CHAMBER.
WE ARE SEEING REPORTS TODAY AND
I KNOW IT’S THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE BUT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DEMOCRATS, JOE MANCHIN OF
WEST VIRGINIA, KYRSTEN SINEMA OF
ARIZONA AMONG THEM, WHO ARE
CONSIDERING A VOTE TO ACQUIT.
DO YOU THINK THAT IS TRUE, AND
IF IT IS, WHAT DOES IT TELL US?
>> I THINK IT’S VERY POSSIBLE,
TUCKER, IT TELLS HER THAT THEY
JUST DO NOT HAVE A CASE.
I THINK WE ARE WATCHING HERE THE
QUESTIONING TONIGHT, THE
DEMOCRATIC CASE JUST FALL APART.
I CAME FROM THE FLOOR, WE ARE IN
RECESS HERE.
ADAM SCHIFF SAID ON THE FLOOR
THAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT BRIBERY,
EXTORTION.
THAT’S WHAT’S GOING ON HERE.
BUT THE HOUSE DID IN CHARGE
BRIBERY OR EXTORTION, THEY DID
NOT ALLEGE THAT IN THE ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT.
WE ARE WONDERING, WHY ARE WE
HERE EXACTLY?
THEY DON’T EVEN KNOW.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ARE
SENSING THAT AND I WOULDN’T BE
SURPRISED IF WE PICKED UP SOME
VOTES.
>> YOU ARE SAYING, THE UNITED
STATE SENATOR SPENT ALL DAY AT
THE IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AND ASKED
THE BIG QUESTIONS LIKE, WHY ARE
WE HERE?
THAT’S DEEPLY REVEALING.
THIS IS HYPOTHETICAL, BUT IT
TURNS OUT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
DON’T HOLD THE LINE, SOME VOTE
TO ACQUIT, WHAT WILL THEY SAY AT
THAT POINT, I WONDER?
AS A PARTY?
>> I THINK THEY ARE JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO ADMIT THAT THIS WAS
ILL-ADVISED FROM THE BEGINNING.
WHAT IT REALLY HAS BEEN A
PARTISAN ATTEMPT TO OVERTURN ANY
ELECTION.
THAT’S WHAT IT TURNS DOWN TO.
THEY WANTED TO IMPEACH HIM FROM
DAY ONE, HELL BENT ON DOING IT.
WHOOPS!
THEY ACTIVELY DID IT AND CANNOT
PROVE THE CASE AND PUTTING THE W
COUNTRY THROUGH THIS, TUCKER.
IT’S TIME TO BRING THIS TO AN
END.
LET’S VOTE.
THEY DO NOT HAVE A CASE.
>> THERE’S BEEN SOME WRANGLING
OVER WHETHER THEY HAVE WITNESSES
WITNESSES, BIG PICTURE.
ARE YOU SENSING THAT THERE IS
ANY REPUBLICAN TONIGHT WHO MIGHT
VOTE TO CONVICT.
>> I NEVER CAN SPEAK FOR ANYBODY
ELSE.
I WILL SAY THAT THE REPUBLIC
CONFERENCES THAT PEOPLE ARE
READY TO VOTE.
WE’VE ADMITTED ALL OF THE
HOUSE’S EVIDENCE IN THE RECORD
INCLUDING TESTIMONY FROM 17
WITNESSES.
ALL OF THAT BEFORE US.
ON THE RECORD, TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU, I HAVE A HARD TIME
IMAGINING THAT SOMEONE WOULD
VOTE TO CONVICT, THE EVIDENCE IS
JUST NOT THERE AND I HAVE NOT
HEARD ANYBODY SAY THEY THINK IT
IS.
BUT WE WILL SEE.
>> Tucker: THAT SUCH A GOOD
POINT AND IT’S NOT AS IF THERE
IS A LOT OF UNITED STATES
SENATORS WITH LONG-STANDING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
PRESUMABLY, IF THERE WAS
EVIDENCE OVERWHELMING AND A
CRIME WAS COMMITTED, YOU
WOULDN’T SEE A LOSS OF SOME
REPUBLICANS, WOULDN’T YOU?
>> LET’S BE HONEST HERE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF SENATORS ON
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE WE DO NOT
LIKE THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WOULD BE HAPPY TO VOTE
AGAINST THEM, REALLY, SOME OF
THEM, IF THEY CAN FIND GROUNDS
TOO.
THEY CAN’T FIND ANY GROUNDS TO
BECAUSE THERE AREN’T ANY AND THE
LONGER THE HOUSE MANAGERS TALK,
THE MORE OBVIOUS THAT BECOMES.
>> Tucker: I THINK THAT’S
RIGHT.